North Korean leader Kim jong-un has
departed Vietnam following the breakdown
of his summit with US President Donald
Trump
Kim's journey home on his private
armored train is expected to take more
than 60 hours it comes amid fresh
controversy over the case of otto
warmbier an American student who was
detained and tortured in North Korea
warmbier was returned to his family in
the u.s. in a vegetative state in 2017
and he died days later President Donald
Trump has said he's confident Kim did
not know about it the two countries and
says they'll continue dialogue
despite the failed summit well for more
on all this I'm joined in the studio now
by Behrendt Berger he's an Asia expert
at the German Council on Foreign
Relations mr. Berger thank you so much
for being here
so once Donald Trump abruptly departed
Hanoi the North Korean leader Kim
jong-un stepped into the spotlight we
saw him laying wreaths he was meeting
with Vietnamese officials what kind of
image was he trying to convey well I
think first of all he was as surprised
aver as everyone else was that this
summit was suddenly over what he did was
he used the opportunity to pay a
goodwill visit to Vietnam North Korea
and in Vietnam have long-standing
relationships they have even modest
trade and due to the sanctions of course
restricted and and they will of course
sit together and see how they can
cooperate in the future and have visits
like symbolic visits to the grave of
former leaders well Donald Trump said he
left the summit because North Korea was
demanding complete sanctions relief
North Korean officials then immediately
denied it we saw them calling quite a
rare press conference even to deny this
so who do we believe and where did
engage a shion's go from here well the
new openness of the North Korean
leadership issus cha also demonstrates
that there buffle dand they really want
to set things straight and if you look
at the consultations that happened
before and the whole process that is
under
it's obvious that they have not actually
demanded full sanctions relief but going
for step by step approach well first of
all economic sanctions for the incoming
people are lifted so the question is
really what the American administration
is doing right now and what kind of
strategy or tactics they're playing well
there's also been quite a backlash in
the u.s. over what Donald Trump said
regarding the case of otto warmbier of
course the American student who died
after 17 months in North Korean
detention
he said Kim jong-un was unaware of what
was going on how likely is that well one
would think in a small state with a
small town like Pyongyang everyone would
know what's going on but Ono says to
emphasize that warmbier was not a did
today in detention for political reasons
it was due to misconduct under heavy
influence of alcohol so I don't know if
there was a big political decision
behind detaining him and and and and
oversight
all right barons burger and Asia expert
of the German Council on Foreign
Relations many things indeed
you